when we were doing no country you know  everything was pretty much drawn and you  kind of knew what you were doing and it  was it was not dialogue heavy so there  wasn't a lot of stuff to experiment with  and change  but i know when i got the  the satchel and i opened it up i said  don't you think he should say something  he looks at the dead guy and then he  looks around and joel goes well like  what i said i don't know like a huh or  like a hmm  and they go  is there anything else and i go  like  like hmm and they go  what else  and then now you're thinking  they're [ __ ] with me right so i went  through about six of them and they go  and ethan said try the second one  so i did the second one  yeah and then every time we screen the  movie once the movie was finished i  always knew where ethan was in the  theater because every time that moment  happened he would burst out laughing  so was it a joke or did it help the  movie and the scene